[Música]
familias judías rodeadas de soldados
alemanes llevadas al campo de Exterminio
de treblinka detrás de ellos El gueto de
Varsovia en llamas 33 fotos en total
obras milagrosamente encontradas en un
ático por el hijo del autor un bombero
polaco a quien llamaron para apagar los
incendios provocados por los nazis
después del estallido en el
levantamiento del gueto de Varsovia el
19 de abril de 1943
estático
él estuvo presente en los últimos
momentos del levantamiento cuando los
que se escondían Desde hacía semanas
salían de sus refugios estaban pálidos
deslumbrados por la luz mi padre decía
que parecían animales que era aterrador
y que fueron tomados por los alemanes
para ser fusilados o para ser deportados
a Campos donde también perecieron
Este era el destino que le esperaba a
los judíos encerrados en este gueto
creado por los alemanes un año después
de la invasión de Polonia en 1939 el 19
de abril de 1943 unos pocos cientos de
ellos atacaron a los nazis preferían
morir a punta de pistola en lugar de ir
a la cámara de gas un momento trágico
que por primera vez se ve con otros ojos
que no sean los de los verdugos
Estas son las únicas fotos cuyo autor no
es alemán y que no fueron tomadas con
fines propagandísticos por lo que tiene
un significado inmenso cambia la
perspectiva de lo que vemos en el gueto
y del holocausto
unas 12 fotos de esta película ya se
conocían pero en un papel de mala
calidad con marcas de huellas dactilares
a partir de abril nuevas tomas serán
exhibidas en el Museo de Historia de los
judíos en Polonia